you know being a best-selling lgbtq plus  children's author the number one  best-selling lgbtq plus children's  author in the world  is a great honor and it also is a huge  responsibility and i'll be honest  there's been some oppression and  persecution has come with it i mean what  i encountered at uh loudoun county  went on dr phil and i've been attacked  by other members of the lgbt community  part of me wants to ask why you care so  much  because it's really not that big of a  deal but at the end of the day it's been  a huge honor for me and i still i just i  try to stay humble about it because  humility is key  some people in the office say this is  all going to my head but  honestly i just don't see it  [Music]  do you want a full reference